hey guys Greg over here and John over
here before our video begins we wanted
to mention to you guys a little
something special Full Sail University
diversity yeah working in the film
industry it's exciting it's a rewarding
experience but if you don't know how to
get involved you're not sure what role
that take in the industry full sails a
great way to help you figure it out and
they got tons of different degrees that
are available on campus or online if
you're not in Florida or whatever that
is they'll basically teach you how to
use all the equipment and do the process
from start to finish and you get to work
hands-on with the same equipment to the
professionals use the campus
undergraduate film program introduces
you to different roles involved in
filmmaking so you can figure out if
you're more of an editor a director or
like even a camera operator like my
neighbor Tony all right well they have
an online a digital cinematography
degree that's available to which is like
it's the cutting edge you know you learn
the basics of film but with you know
modern spin and Full Sail graduates you
know if you want proof have gone on to
work on some pre you know well-known
films you know there was a vengers age
of Ultron minions Jurassic world and
frozen and there's even more than that
so if you want to learn more about you
know their various programs and how to
get started with everything hit the link
in the box below and I think it's
unscreened here yeah yeah so yeah click
that link is full sail university is
rocking
hello guys Greg over here and I'm John
the John and I am Danielle Danielle I
didn't give you a hug Oh nor did I o
people o 1 take a joke I'm gonna turn
into a threesome isn't it yes comedy
gold no we saw that coming hander that
one we're gonna check out from the
lovely Hannah Hart they have a movie or
miniseries coming out Electra woman and
Dyna girl yeah this is a reboot of the
show from the 70s which was I actually
had never seen anything of that show but
from my understanding it's a it's a
reboot of this 70 show that was kind of
like a semi parody of like the Batman
show but instead with two women and
hannah hart is you she is no I don't
she's she's a youtuber oh fun videos oh
so she got like a starring role yeah Jay
plays a [ __ ] trailer all right here
we go on us wrong trail I'm sorry guys
do you know what Daniel I can edit you
out of its not to hire so you have that
kind of power
no well hello gentlemen can shove that
phone so deep inside you you're gonna
have to do kegel stance or it I've never
done kegels but I've heard things weird
thing to protect innocent people and up
straight years and no one seems to
notice how so i'm pretty sure people
notice us now i'm going to upload this
video's all your friends believe enough
to do polish it an agent at seal until
the video wants us to come for me to get
home wow there they are I love
everything about you in one handsome
don't see any toys
to make a bigger difference than we can
in Ohio come on we've been waiting for
girl that's really good yeah
destruction by the police and their gun
fire tonight boring you're gonna trick
me I'd love to help but I really don't
think I should for Los Angeles it's
Electra woman and Dyna girl um I'm here
to your electro woman sidekick Dyna girl
right I'm not a psychic if you're not
willing to follow my lead then spin off
I need to get speci anomalies on the
Wilshire I need to get there as fast as
possible none uber driver get out of my
car mrs. are there in that city give
this up here so you can suit up oh right
here I said suit up not soup up
Los Angeles is that a hole oh it's great
hon did not see that race help
ha okay that's not really good next time
in front of humans in front of humans
hmm ok ok I gotta say though a lot of
what we're getting from like YouTube red
and one youtubers do movies and stuff
this looks like one of the better
versions yeah why you certainly looks
like they have some production value
Danielle how do you really feel would i
watch it you wouldn't want you know why
I do just looks not but you like
superheroes no I like good you know no
super you like I like you know not
Superman but everyone but Superman
really i'm not sure what kind of film
it's supposed to be exactly i was like
oh it's a spoof of superhero films and
then you're like this is just trying to
be a superhero movie actually well he
effort for the first part i almost
thought it was giving it like a kick-ass
sorted out the streets they're doing it
vigilante style but then it seems like
it escalates higher than that and then
some of it almost seems like a situation
comedy about two people trying to like
keep a contract going her salad you know
termines a fancy reminds me of that
movie with them the guy from malcolm in
the middle and amanda bynes big fat liar
yeah yeah i just have that vibe you know
really go by really it does yeah it's a
really weird car to poop that's just who
i came to mind and grace Helbig you know
she's a pretty famous youtuber over 2
million subs unbelief and had a heart
you know they're both funny I think like
they're actually funny youtubers and
it's cool to see like a collaboration of
these two coming together for this I
felt like the funniest parts of the
trailer were when it was like a
back-and-forth of them yeah ya know and
that uber bid was pretty funny too yes
some of the jokes that I'm like it's
kind of a cheap like the whole soup
thing yes you think what and and some of
the jokes are like the funny but the way
they're cut is a little wooden you know
yeah like stuff like that say it kind of
the row is this on youtube red or is
this on like TV I don't know cuz it does
kind of feel still like the internet
first yeah the waves cut and shot and
all that stuff feels like which might be
cool because you know like their
internet stars yeah it makes sense yeah
it could be fun that was the things it
was it was going on for a while and then
I was like oh that's right this is TV
cuz yeah it's just a trailer it's a bit
long and then it starts to drag well I'm
sure their followers will love it I
think it's like it's like a it looks
like a long a line of humor yeah I know
thing and other people who don't know
who they are won't like it when it looks
fun and good nature you know like like
you could read for these two and have a
good time hmm mild peril I'm taking to
any else up there united to add into at
the same dress you know I hate yes I
sepa- the underwear Electra woman and
Dyna girl isn't made for the grace all
right Greg Alice knows having a more
interesting conversation we should have
like that we should have like a sign
that's like you know like I see it not
see it at the end we vote I give it a
hundred years oh wow oh and then we
would give it in vote yeah just yeah
let's do it like the Olympics just nine
points we should get them know that you
can bring my DIY what'll be my DIY three
people in one videos too much no never
know anyway god what if it's playing at
someone's home or if they really want to
watch it I'll definitely I I want to
watch it only because I like Hannah Hart
yeah you know I've actually seen a lot
of her I don't really see much of grace
Helbig stuff but hannah hart i think is
great and you know legendary worked on
it too I like legendary they're a good
company beautiful Oaks good company
shout the Pearl Bible what's going on
pearl it's gonna respond the comments of
what you have listen guys if you need to
the channel subscribe today
reject hashtag reject fantastic cheer on
has risen to Jerry and dank ass tubs
those are his little shows on this
channel this tiny little channel and
danielle has an Instagram to there it's
full of bikini photos that I am
constantly looking at constantly know
people in a missed shot through the roof
you know wouldn't believe and if you're
lucky you'll get a little poop if you're
lucky hmm ok Willie other people's asses
or so are your anus more like a mixture
no you can't really have the shots
Instagram doesn't allow it but she's
trying but a star all right you put a
star won't be the point of it I would
like that you can imagine this is a
see-through dress Tron well I was there
where he wasn't there is there on
Saturday no he wasn't yes you what is up
John were you with us on saturday night
what are you talking back yes you were
Saturday I went to Saturday night you
were with us and I was tripping out on
the edible know you talked about Batman
vs super him at the hotel like midnight
maybe you read the hotel no you know
this was a see-through dress he wasn't
the hotel I know but you were laying
under the sheets yeah this on Saturday
no you shut up at the hotel later I
thought you were [ __ ] over there yes i
did show of the hotel i didn't i didn't
know a little jump good you got it it
still reported no I cut it and then
started in your take so if we can just
finish it you want to finish that bit
there we roof oh we already did the
shadows to [ __ ] shall we continue